El futuro de las pensiones es hoy uno de
los temas más candentes y que más
controversia genera. ¿Son las pensiones
sostenibles? ¿Qué sistema de pensiones es
mejor: el sistema de reparto de España o
el sistema de capitalización de Chile?
Precisamente en los últimos años las
protestas en Chile han arreciado contra
un sistema de capitalización al que
muchos tachan de injusto, ineficiente e
insolidario.
¿Pero qué hay de verdad en todo esto?
Para contestar a estas incógnitas hoy
tenemos aquí en VisualPolitik a
Juan Ramón Rallo, uno de los mejores
economistas de España, colaborador
habitual en radio, prensa y televisión y
director del Instituto Juan de Mariana.
Pues bien, ¡vamos allá!
El modelo de pensiones chileno es bastante
diferente al modelo que conocemos en
España se basa en un sistema de
capitalización que por lo general suele
explicarse bastante mal y,  por tanto, suele
resultar bastante controvertido para
todos aquellos que lo escuchan por
primera vez. Es muy probable de hecho que
durante los últimos meses hayáis visto
que este sistema está siendo objeto de
feroces críticas por parte de muchos de
sus detractores dentro y fuera de Chile.
Durante el año 2016 se han llevado a
cabo numerosas manifestaciones y
protestas no siempre pacíficas contra
este modelo que algunos han vendido como
un éxito pero que a la vista, a la luz
de estas protestas, parecería que es un
rotundo fracaso.
"Estamos acá haciendo el paro nacional
porque estamos convencidos que estamos
con un sistema previsional nefasto
para nuestro país, nefasto para los
trabajadores y trabajadoras de Chile, y
necesitamos nuevo sistema previsional.
Ahora bien, antes de explorar más en
detalle el modelo chileno, empecemos
recordando que existen dos modelos
fundamentalmente distintos para las
pensiones:
el modelo de reparto y el modelo de
capitalización. Los sistemas de reparto
consisten esencialmente en que a los
trabajadores de hoy se les quita una
parte de su salario presente para pagar
las pensiones de los jubilados también
de hoy. Todo suena muy bonito, todo suena
muy a solidaridad intergeneracional
pero eso funciona mientras la pirámide
poblacional adopte una forma adecuada. Si
la pirámide poblacional comienza a
invertirse, de tal forma que cada vez hay
menos trabajadores por cada pensionista
entonces este modelo tan idílico tan
solidario empieza a flaquear.
Lo vamos a ver a lo largo del vídeo en
el caso de España pero ya os adelanto
que el resultado sobre todo a medio-
largo plazo no va a ser nada positivo.
Por otro lado, están los sistemas de
capitalización que consisten
básicamente en que los trabajadores
cada trabajador aporta una parte de su
salario a una cuenta de ahorro
individual a una cuenta de ahorro
personalizadas una especie de hucha para
cada trabajador donde los ahorros se
invierten y crecen cada año también a
través de la reinversión de los
rendimientos de estas inversiones. Vamos
metiendo euros dólares cada mes los
invertimos esas inversiones generan
renta y las rentas que generan esas
inversiones
a su vez las reinvertimos otra vez en la
hucha
Entre los modelos de pensiones que
podemos encontrar el sistema chileno es
el que más se acerca al sistema de
capitalización ideal y también el más
exitoso. Pero entonces os preguntaréis,
¿por qué recibe tantas críticas? ¿ha sido
realmente un fracaso un fiasco para
todos los ahorradores tal y como los
críticos afirman?
Uno de los argumentos clave en contra
del modelo de capitalización
chileno es ofrecer un dato que desde
luego a simple vista parece desolador
y es que la pensión media mensual en
chile en ese modelo tan exitoso del que
estamos hablando
apenas asciende a 282 euros es decir
menos de 3.400 euros anuales,
por tanto parece a simple vista que se
trata de una minucia de un absoluto
fracaso frente a las pensiones que se
pagan por ejemplo en sistemas que pueden
ser criticables como el sistema de
reparto español pero que al final
terminan ofreciendo pensiones claramente
superiores. Ahora bien, lo cierto
y más allá de estas cifras que ahora
vamos a desgranar es que para analizar
el sistema de pensiones chileno hay que mirar un
poco más en profundidad y no dejarse
llevar por las primeras impresiones que
desde luego lo calificarían o
permitirían calificarlo de un sistema
que no permite pagar pensiones muy
abultadas. Primero, es verdad que las
pensiones en España son como media
cuatro veces superiores a las pensiones
medias de Chile y eso a pesar de que la
renta per cápita española sólo es el
doble que la chilena o dicho de otra
manera sería justificable sería
relativamente justificable que las
pensiones españolas fueran el doble que
las chilenas simplemente por el
diferencial de renta per cápita entre
países lo que no se justifica es que sean
cuatro veces más altas que las chilenas.
Por tanto tenemos que inspeccionar más
en detalle estos datos, y lo primero
que hay que decir al respecto es que hay
que tener mucho cuidado con esa aparente
generosidad del sistema público
español de pensiones porque como ahora
vamos a comprobar
se trata de un espejismo que durante
los próximos años inevitablemente se
va a desmoronar. Por tanto, podríamos
estar comparando un sistema de pensiones
sostenible como el de Chile con un
sistema de pensiones es insostenible
como el español y por tanto
evidentemente el sistema insostenible
de momento puede pagar pensiones
sustancialmente más altas que sistema
sostenible.
De hecho, para darnos cuenta de esa
insostenibilidad tenemos que empezar
recordando que hoy en el momento en que
estás viendo vídeo el sistema
público de pensiones español ya es
deficitario y es que en 2016 este
déficit alcanzó la cifra de nada menos
que de 18.000 millones de euros
Pero ahí no queda la cosa, no.  Este agujero
se va a ir incrementando década tras
década con el paso del tiempo.
Por consiguiente, no sólo estamos
comparando un sistema como el chileno
que puede ser sostenible con uno como el
español que tiene problemas muy graves
de sostenibilidad sino que además
esa comparación resulta tan tramposa
por dos elementos que no son homogéneos
entre ambos países y esos dos elementos
no homogéneos son los que aparentemente le
conceden a las pensiones españolas una
mayor magnitud que las chilenas pero es
muy importante analizar cada una de
estas trampas para comprobar por qué el
sistema español no va a ser capaz de
pagar pensiones tan altas como las
actuales. Primera trampa: una tasa de
reemplazo insostenible.
¿Por qué el actual sistema de pensiones
español es insostenible? Empecemos
hablando de la tasa de reemplazo que va
a ser el concepto clave para entender
esta insostenibilidad. La tasa de
reemplazo atentos es el porcentaje del
último salario que un jubilado percibe
en forma de pensión: es decir si yo a los
64 años estoy ganando 15.000 euros en
un trabajo y me jubilo con 7.500 euros
de pensión
la tasa de reemplazo sería del 50%
Es un concepto importante para
tener en cuenta cuál va a ser el salto
en el nivel de vida de los jubilados
cuando se jubilen, porque si yo vengo
disfrutando de un salario de 15 mil y me
pasan de golpe a un salario de 7.500
o tengo ahorros o voy a tener que dar un
salto a la baja muy importante en mi
calidad de vida. Pues bien, España hoy
en día es el segundo país de la OCDE
con una tasa de reemplazo más alta de
las pensiones públicas pero decir es el
segundo país de la OCDE donde las
pensiones públicas representan a un
mayor porcentaje del último salario
percibido. ¿Qué porcentaje? Pues a día de
hoy en torno al 80%, no del último
salario sino del salario medio que cobra
un español a lo largo de toda su vida
laboral.
En cambio en chile esta tasa es del 40%,
es decir, prácticamente la
mitad justo la mitad que en España.
Ahora bien como decía esta alta tasa de
reemplazo que sería magnífica si se
pudiese mantener en el tiempo va a ser
por desgracia insostenible en el caso
de España.
Hoy en día españa cuenta casi con dos
trabajadores por pensionista y eso es lo
que permite sostener financiar esa alta
tasa de reemplazo insisto la segunda
más alta de toda la ocde. Pero por
desgracia la tendencia es a que esta
tasa de crecer a lo largo del tiempo
de hecho si miramos las series
demográficas del instituto nacional de
estadística
analizamos las estimaciones que hacen
organismos como el gobierno el fondo
maitén internacional o la ocede
comprobaremos que para el año 2050 se
espera atención que sólo haya un
trabajador por cada pensión que deba
abonar el sistema y el significado de
esto es evidente si hoy la tasa de
reemplazo del 80% de las pensiones se
sustenta sobre dos trabajadores por
pensionista y vamos a tener sólo un
trabajador por pensionista
eso significa que el hachazo a las pensiones públicas va a
tener que ser de órdago
De hecho en las previsiones que maneja el
propio gobierno de españa y que ha
remitido a la unión europea para
estudiar la sostenibilidad a largo plazo
del sistema de pensiones
las conclusiones son clarísimas y
negrísimas se estima que la tasa de
reemplazo en españa se irá reduciendo
hasta situarse por debajo del 50 por
ciento en el año 2060
es decir pasaremos de un 80 por ciento
casi 80 por ciento de tasa de reemplazo
a menos del 50% y además tengamos lo
presente esa previsión del gobierno que
no es precisamente halagüeña se basa
en una serie de estimaciones de
pronósticos sobre nuestro futuro que
además son bastante optimistas por
ejemplo el gobierno considera que en el
año 2060... Estamos hablando del año 2060 es decir
no son capaces de prever cuál va a ser
la tasa de paro dentro de 3, 4 años pues
imaginémonos dentro de más de 40 años
pero bueno en el año 2060
el gobierno espera que para que la tasa
de reemplazo solo caiga por debajo del
50% de los últimos salarios percibidos
en españa será necesario que esté
trabajando el 73% de la población en
edad de trabajar
Esto es un porcentaje más alto que en
ningún otro momento de nuestra historia
para que nos hagamos una idea en el
mejor momento de la historia económica
de este país o aparentemente el mejor
momento en el pico de la burbuja
inmobiliaria cuando la economía
parecía ir a todo tren y atabamos a los
perros con longanizas el porcentaje de
población en edad de trabajar que
tenía un empleo era sólo del 66% en
los que el gobierno necesita que en el
año 2060 el 73% de las personas en edad
de trabajar tengan un empleo para que la
tasa de reemplazo de las pensiones sólo
caído un 50 por ciento pero en el mejor
momento de nuestra historia sólo
trabajó el 66 por ciento no 73 por
tanto si en lugar de llegar al 73% nos
quedamos en el 66 o 65% la caída de la
tasa de reemplazo todavía sería mayor
y con ello las pensiones si la tasa de
reemplazo cae, las pensiones también
caen
tal vez por ello las propias comisiones
obreras no estamos quitando tampoco
fuentes muy contrarias al sistema
público de pensiones
el sindicato comisiones obreras estima
que en el año 2060 las pensiones que
podrá pagar el sistema de seguridad
social español apenas representarán el
40% de los salarios que ha percibido ese
trabajador durante su vida laboral.
Echad cuentas: el 80 por ciento hoy,
el 50 ó 40 por ciento en 2060 de que
les suena una tasa de reemplazo del 40
por ciento pues justamente es la que hoy
está pagando el sistema chileno.
En Chile la tasa de reemplazo no se prevé
que caiga a lo largo de las próximas
décadas porque el sistema si es
sostenible al basarse en un sistema de
ahorro personal
el caso es que si en españa hoy
tuviésemos la tasa de reemplazo que
vamos a padecer a lo largo de las
próximas décadas
la pensión media de españa sería de
7.700 euros anuales unos 650 euros al
mes por tanto poco más del doble de la
que ya está pagando hoy el sistema
chilenos
bien pongamos en perspectiva todo lo que
hemos visto hasta ahora
al principio del vídeo veíamos que la
pensión media española era cuatro
veces superior a la pensión media
chilena a pesar de que el nivel de renta
en españa es sólo el doble pues bien
como hemos visto la tasa de reemplazo
actual en españa es insostenible por lo
que en los próximos años va a tener
que reducirse drásticamente y con ella
las pensiones al corregir esa tasa
vemos que las pensiones de España y
Chile se ajustan y finalmente su
diferencia se explicará sólo por el
diferente nivel de riqueza de cada país
pero aquí todavía tenemos que entrar
en la segunda trampa que se suele
introducir en las comparaciones entre
España y Chile
y es justamente que el sistema público
de pensiones español es muchísimo
más caro para un trabajador que el
sistema privado de pensiones chilenos
¿pero cuánto más caro?
Segunda trampa unas cotizaciones sociales
altísimas bien en españa las
cotizaciones a la seguridad social que
van a financiar las pensiones públicas
representan el 28,3 por ciento del
salario bruto de cada trabajador
en chile en cambio es sólo del 10% por
tanto los chilenos pagan cotizan ahorran
para su jubilación
casi tres veces menos que en españa
y ésta es justamente la clave es la
tasa de reemplazo de las pensiones en
españa es aproximadamente el doble que
hoy en chile pero las cotizaciones
sociales son el triple
por tanto hoy en españa pagamos el
triple para recibir sólo el doble y
esto insisto es así con una tasa de
reemplazo del 80 por ciento pero ya
hemos visto ya hemos previsto como estas
tasas de reemplazo va a terminar cayendo
a un porcentaje entre el 40 y el 50% de
los salarios en españa por tanto a
medio largo plazo
los españoles van a tener que pagar el
triple van a tener que ahorrar el
triplete van a tener que reponer cidel
triples en su consumo en su nivel de
vida que los chilenos para conseguir
aproximadamente la misma pensión en
términos relativos que en chile es una
trampa por tanto, ¿dónde está esa
supuesta eficiencia maravillosa esa
magnífica solidaridad intergeneracional
del sistema público de pensiones
español frente al fiasco del sistema
privado de pensiones chileno? En ningún
lado. Un punto en cinco entradas en las
que chile nos hubiesen ingresado en el
sistema de pensiones lo mismo que un
español a lo largo de su vida laboral
es decir si hubiesen ahorrado mes a mes
el 28,3 por ciento de su salario
hoy los chilenos contarían con una tasa
de reemplazo del 105 por ciento es decir
una persona un jubilado se jubilaría
con una pensión superior al salario que
ha percibido a lo largo de su vida
laboral
por supuesto es verdad los chilenos
cuentan con la libertad si así lo
quisieran de ahorrar más del 10% de su
salario cada mes para la jubilación
ese 10% es sólo el porcentaje que el
gobierno les obliga a ahorrar para
prever una jubilación más o menos
adecuada es por tanto un chileno medio
siquiera una pensión más alta una
pensión que supere con creces a
pensión relativas del sistema público
español sólo tiene que ahorrar lo
mismo que se ahorra forzosamente en el
sistema público español y así incluso
con la insostenible tasa de reemplazo
actual en chile se pagan pensiones
relativamente más altas que en españa
así que se considera y y ahora me
dirijo a vosotros amigos chilenos que
probablemente nos estáis escuchando que
las pensiones de vuestro modelo actual
son demasiado bajas que son
insuficientes es simplemente tenéis que
incrementar vuestra aportación al
sistema de ahorro privado al sistema de
ahorros personales por encima del 10%
no tenéis que copiar el sistema
público de pensiones español
el sistema público de pensiones
español os obligar a ahorrar el 30% no
el 10 y el 30 por ciento de nuestros
salarios para recibir menos de lo que
estéis recibiendo ahora mismo y sí ya
sé que muchos a lo mejor está
dispensando es imposible que en chile
con los bajos salarios que se perciben
un trabajador ahorre el 30% de su
salario por tanto parecería yo sistema
privado de pensiones y no ofrece una
solución para todos aquellos que no
tienen capacidad de ahorro pero nos
confundamos el sistema público español
es exactamente igual en ese sentido en
españa si no ahorra el 30% de su
salario sino cocinas a la seguridad
social por el 30 por ciento de sus
salarios tampoco partida extensión por
tanto si voluntariamente un chileno no
es capaz de ahorrar el 30 por ciento en
los salarios porque cree que no va a
llegar a fin de mes que sucederá si se
le obliga a orar es de 30 por ciento no
siendo capaz de borrarlos de de su
salario percibido mensualmente
puntos débiles del sistema chileno
por supuesto todo esto no quiere decir
que sistema dádiva o perfiles que menor
sea perfecto y que no necesite de
cambios o de mejoras un primer error por
ejemplo de alguna manera lanzar
políticamente el mensaje a los chilenos
que si sólo ahorrando el 10% que les
obligaba a ahorrar el sector público
para sus cuentas de ahorro personal
accederían apariciones que todo el
mundo considerarán dignas y suficientes
por bueno quizá no tenía por qué ser
así
quizá el sector público no debería
haber vendido que sólo con el 10 por
ciento con ese ahorro mínimo
obligatorio que podía acceder a
pensiones adecuadas quizá debería
haber simplemente dejado a la
discrecionalidad de cada chilenos que
determinará su tasa de ahorro en
función de la pensión a la que espera
y desea poder llegar a cobrar en el
futuro y en segundo lugar si le necesita
mucha más competencia entre sus fondos
privados de pensiones
quizá por un asunto o esencialmente
paternalista el estado chileno ha
restringido el número y el tipo de
fondos en los que los chilenos pueden
acumular ahorros como diciéndoles estos
fondos son buenos estos fondos tienen
una marca de garantía del estado
podéis confiar en ellos y por tanto ese
10% de ahorro mensual obligatorio
tenéis que destinarlo también
obligatoriamente alguno de estos fondos
que cuentan con mi aprobación problema
de esto que este espíritu paternalista
del estado ha terminado generando un
oligopolio entre los fondos privados de
pensiones chilenos porque el chileno no
pues de no ahorrar y no invertir en esos
fondos sino destinar ese esa porción de
ese salario mensual a otro tipo de
inversiones y esto con un poder de
negociación alto porque el estado
obliga a que así sea a esos fondos
privilegiados con la aprobación estatal
porque no abrir mucho más el sistema la
competencia porque no permitir que cada
chileno se responsabilicen no sólo de
cuánto ahorra cada mes y no de dónde
invierte el ahorro que ahorra aranés en
definitiva amigos chilenos no os dejéis
engañar por cantos
deciden a en tema de pensiones no hope i
de españa
un saludo a todos y hasta la próxima